Por si hace mucho que no han estado en una clase de historia,
esto es lo que dice la Segunda Enmienda, sorprendentemente dice:
"Al ser una milicia bien regulada,
necesaria para la seguridad de un estado libre,
el derecho del pueblo a tener y portar armas,
no será violado."
Es decir, el gobierno federal no podría infringir los derechos de los ciudadanos
a participar en milicias bien reguladas.
La segunda enmienda fue ratificada hace 226 años.
Fue escrita tiempo antes de que las fuerzas armadas del gobierno federal
se hallaran entre las más poderosos del mundo,
cuando las milicias del estado
se consideraban necesarias para proteger los estados.
Demos un salto, 80 años, hasta 1871.
La guerra civil estadounidense había terminado unos años antes,
pero un par de oficiales de la Unión
habían sido testigos de punterías bastante mala en el campo de batalla.
Así que para preparar a sus hombres para cualquier conflicto futuro,
fundaron la Asociación Nacional del Rifle
para fomentar el uso del rifle.
En resumen, la Segunda Enmienda fue escrita para asegurar
que nuestro país recién formado y frágil
tuviera acceso a milicias estatales organizadas.
Y la misión original de la NRA
era asegurar que los futuros soldados tuvieran un buen objetivo.
Cualquiera podría dar un curso completo
sobre cómo los próximos 150 años
influyeron en las conversaciones de regulación de armas
que estamos teniendo en EE. UU.
y nuestra interpretación de la Segunda Enmienda.
Casi todos los momentos cruciales en la historia de nuestra nación
de una forma u otra, influyeron en cómo nosotros como pueblo
fabricamos, debatimos, regulamos y sentimos las armas de fuego.
Se han producido muchos cambios.
De hecho, no fue hasta 2008
que el Tribunal Supremo reguló por primera vez
que la Segunda Enmienda protegiera
el derecho individual a poseer un arma de fuego
independientemente de estar al servicio de una milicia,
y a usar ese arma para fines tradicionalmente legales,
como la autodefensa dentro del hogar.
¡Dentro del hogar!
Este cambio en el tiempo es sorprendente para mí,
porque nos recuerda
que la interpretación de la Segunda Enmienda
y las actitudes culturales sobre las armas de fuego
han cambiado con el tiempo.
Lo cual me da la esperanza de que pueda cambiar otra vez.
(Aplausos)
Es una lección de historia dinámica e increíblemente compleja,
pero no es la lección que pretendo enseñar hoy,
porque no tenemos tiempo.
No estoy hablando sobre el tiempo,
el tiempo que tengo para estar aquí y hablar.
Hablo del hecho de que no tenemos tiempo que perder.
Según la CDC,
en los últimos cinco años,
de media, cada día 96 personas son asesinadas por armas de fuego en EE. UU.,
y si no descubrimos cómo responder a la pregunta de mis estudiantes pronto,
uno de nosotros podría ser el siguiente.
Y, si la pregunta es,
cómo detenemos esta descabellada violencia,
la mejor manera que se me ocurre responder
es viendo las opciones múltiples.
Recuerdan las preguntas de elección múltiple en el instituto, ¿no?
Empecemos. Opción A:
esto terminará cuando responsabilicemos a los fabricantes de armas
por la letalidad de sus productos.
Puede que les sorprenda saber que de hecho hemos pensado en esto antes.
Entre 1998 y 2000
30 condados y ciudades demandaron a fabricantes de armas,
alegando que deberían hacer sus productos más seguros,
y un mejor seguimiento de dónde se vendían sus productos.
En respuesta, los fabricantes alegaron
que no tenían responsabilidad directa de cómo se usaban sus productos.
Dijeron que las tiendas que vendían las armas
y los dueños que los compraban eran responsables si algo malo sucedía.
En respuesta a ésta y muchas otras demandas,
la NRA presionó para la aprobación de la PLCAA,
la Protección del Comercio Legal contra los Actos de Armas.
La PLCAA se aprobó con el apoyo bipartidista en 2005,
y protege a los fabricantes de armas
que las diseñan de forma segura,
a los establecimientos que las venden responsablemente
y a aquellos que las poseen y las usan con responsabilidad.
Y así cuando 17 estudiantes y profesores mueren en mi escuela,
nadie en esta cadena asumirá la responsabilidad.
Echemos un vistazo a otra opción,
opción B:
esto terminará cuando nos hagamos responsables
y regulemos los aproximadamente 300 millones de armas disponibles
en EE. UU.
Sí, votar es una de las mejores maneras de aceptar
nuestra responsabilidad personal por la violencia armada.
Asegurarnos de que nuestros legisladores
están dispuestos a aprobar una reforma de armas racional,
es una de las formas más efectivas
de conseguir el control de esos 300 millones de armas.
También los dueños de las armas puede tener iniciativa personal.
Si poseen un arma,
pregúntese:
¿Tengo un arma extra que no necesito?
¿Podría caer en las manos equivocadas?
¿He asistido a la última capacitación?
Tal vez como propietarios de un arma,
también deberían preguntarse
si han estado cuidando su salud mental.
Cuando se trata de violencia con armas, el argumento de la salud mental fracasa
si no reconocemos nuestras propias vulnerabilidades personales
a la enfermedad mental.
Uno de cada seis estadounidenses luchará con la enfermedad mental.
Si tenemos un arma, deberíamos comprometernos rigurosamente a mantener
nuestro bienestar emocional
para que no disparemos un gatillo
cuando enfermemos.
De lo contrario, deberíamos preguntarnos seriamente
si realmente tenemos el tiempo y atención necesarios para poseer un arma.
Quizás para algunos de nosotros
es hora de dejar nuestras armas.
Entonces tenemos la Opción C:
terminará cuando mejoremos en cuidarnos los unos a los otros.
Muchos problemas sociales provocan que la gente compre y use armas.
El 62 % de las muertes por armas de fuego en EE. UU.
entre 2012 y 2016 fueron suicidios.
Sin embargo, seguimos llamándolos maníacos y psicópatas, avergonzándolos.
Estamos creando barreras para las personas que necesitan ayuda.
¿Por qué nos avergonzamos los unos de los otros?
Hagámoslo más fácil, no más difícil,
para que puedan acceder a una mejor asistencia de salud mental.
¿Qué más? el sexismo, el racismo y la pobreza provocan la posesión de armas
y las muertes relacionadas con ellas.
De media, se estima que al mes 50 mujeres fueron mortalmente asesinadas
entre 2010 y 2014,
debido a violencia doméstica.
Y siguen muriendo mujeres en sus hogares.
Vamos a empoderar a las mujeres
y a darles a nuestros hijos la oportunidad
de aprender cómo resolver sus conflictos y emociones con palabras, no con armas.
El "Washington Post" informó que el año pasado,
casi 1000 personas resultaron fatalmente heridas
por oficiales de policía en servicio.
Hablen con Black Lives Matter y el sindicato policial sobre eso.
Tenemos que hacer frente a esto.
(Aplausos)
Al final,
tal vez, la gente no sentirá la necesidad
de comprar y usar un arma
cuando todos se sientan igualmente seguros,
saludables, respetados y cuidados.
Muy bien, el tiempo de debate ha acabado.
Y es hora de responder la pregunta.
¿Cómo detenemos esta descabellada violencia?
¿Es la opción A,
la opción B,
o la opción C?
Bueno, sé lo que todos están pensando.
que las preguntas de respuestas múltiples
casi nunca terminan con solo tres posibilidades.
Siempre está esa cuarta, opción D: todas son correctas.
Tal vez esa sea la respuesta aquí.
O tal vez "todas son correctas" sea demasiado fácil,
y este no es un problema fácil.
Requiere una profunda reflexión analítica por parte de todos nosotros.
Por tanto, lo que les estoy pidiendo es que hagan sus deberes,
escriban su propia elección D
usando toda la información.
Y si no están seguros por dónde empezar,
tomen a mis estudiantes como ejemplo.
Están armados con increíbles destrezas comunicativas
y un sentido de la ciudadanía que me parece muy inspirador.
(Aplausos)
Estos son los niños de las escuelas públicas comprometidos
con los tema de la regulación de armas,
y su esfuerzo ha conmovido nuestros corazones.
Y no deberían tener que hacer esto por su cuenta.
Les están pidiendo,
nos están pidiendo a todos,
que nos involucremos.
Esto no es un espetáculo.
Por tanto, ¿cuál es la respuesta correcta?
No lo sé. No soy una experta en control de armas.
Yo enseño humanidades.
Ser humano es aprender,
y ser parte de una civilización es compartir el conocimiento.
Este tipo de honestidad, de compromiso valiente y sincero
es lo que les pido a mis alumnos,
lo que espero de mí mismo como maestro
y lo que les exijo a Uds. ahora.
Cada uno de Uds. necesita hacer sus deberes.
¿Y después qué?
Humildemente compartan sus conocimientos los unos a los otros.
Por favor enséñenle a su familia,
enseñen a su comunidad,
su ayuntamiento, su legislación.
Enseñen al Congreso una lección.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)
Gracias. Gracias.